après le début de la crise des migrants
à la frontière entre l'inde et la russie
et la pologne nous avons appris qu'il ya
de bons réfugiés que l'union européenne
accepte à bras ouverts et de mauvais qui
déstabilise le les mêmes personnes qui
autrefois appelée à accueillir les
exilés affirme désormais qu'il faut les
renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine et
bien sûr sanctionner les responsables de
cette crise la commission est prête à
considérer les moyens budgétaires
nécessaires pour soutenir les pays
membres de l'ua qui s'engageront à
réinstaller les réfugiés la biélorussie
doit arrêter de mettre les vies des gens
en danger j'appelle à une approbation
des sanctions renforcées à de possibles
sanctions vis-à-vis des compagnies
aériennes de pays tiers qui pourrait
être impliquée dans cette affaire nous
veillons également à prévenir une crise
humanitaire et assurer un retour à la
sécurité quant aux responsables de la
crise migratoire ce ne sont évidemment
pas les pays qu'ils ont envahi l'irak
ont même parfois financés les
djihadistes en séries mais le grand
méchant de l'est la russie a une
responsabilité claire à cet égard elle
doit faire pression sur les autorités
biélorusses pour qu'elle mette fin à la
crise et entament un dialogue on entend
même des appels à sanctionner la
compagnie aérienne russe aeroflot qui
n'a même pas de vols réguliers en syrie
en irak ou de lignes directes istanbul
minsk
nous n'avons rien à voir avec cela rien
du tout elle est pourquoi nous dit-on
cela dont nous les laissons à leur
conscience ils veulent tout simplement
rejeté leur mauvaise conscience sur les
autres c'est uniquement leur faute j'ai
déjà expliqué pourquoi pour des raisons
politiques militaires économiques
ils ont eux mêmes créé les conditions
nécessaires pour que des milliers des
centaines de milliers de personnes
aillent chez eux et maintenant ils
cherchent des coupables pour se
décharger de la responsabilité de ce qui
se passe
quel rapport avec notre compagnie
aérienne aeroflot est ce qu'un seul
avion d'aero flotte à transporter
quelqu'un je n'en ai aucune idée vous
comprenez quelqu'un aurait probablement
pu se servir de cet avion et voyager via
des pays tiers mais quel est le rapport
avec nous je le répète ce n'est qu'un
désir de se décharger de la
responsabilité des événements qui se
déroulent maintenant l'union européenne
annonce qu'elle va sanctionner la
biélorussie pour la crise des migrants
ont cherche des prétextes pour
sanctionner également la russie mais on
n'entende pas un mot de compassion pour
les milliers de personnes bloquées dans
le froid sans eau ni nourriture
la politique américaine ces deux poids
deux mesures car si on se demande où se
trouvent les racines de la crise
actuelle les réponses sont la guerre les
sanctions et les exportations d'armes
l'union européenne se présente toujours
comme une union libéral qui respecte le
droit de l'homme mais ce que nous
observons maintenant s'est déjà produit
aux frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne où les gens avaient besoin
des de nourriture d'eau et d'assistance
médicale mais les personnes et leur
dignité se sont retrouvés au second plan
et la racine du problème ce n'est
certainement pas la biélorussie ce
problème a commencé lorsque l'union
européenne les états unis et l'otan ont
soutenu les guerres en syrie en irak en
afghanistan et dans de nombreux autres
pays